excellent so yes I'm very excited to be
here it's an extremely exciting workshop
and you know very exciting day and I
think that's because in particular were
you know you know a very exciting period
in sort of the history of quantum
computing where we're seeing this sort
of unprecedented convergence of
experiment and theory and this is sort
of what this workshop is all about and
in particular I think one of the best
examples of this you know just happened
at the end of last year was this this
quantum supremacy experiment that Google
published late last year and you know
we're really happy to have today you
know one of the one of the leads of that
experiment from from the Google team
Sergio boy show here to tell us more so
Sergio let me pass pass it to you
all right thank you so um I guess I will
start my presentation let me share my
screen okay is that working
yeah I can release an ice cream perfect
yes I thank you very much for the nice
introduction because I'm gonna talk a
bit about this experiment that we
performed less here and the paper that
we publish is called quantum supremacy
using a programmable superconducting
processor so see ok so this is the team
working in this experiment pretty much
everyone into oval a lot of
experimentalist and a fair amount of
theorists as well so just give a very
basic overview of what we were trying to
do in demonstrating Quentin supremacy we
choose a computational problem which is
just a sample of the distribution of a
random quantum circuit and then we
compare the best quantum strategy which
is just to run the quantum circuit and a
quantum processor with the best
classical strategy available which is to
to sample the same circuit using a
supercomputer and to sample the same
circuit we actually have to simulate
this circuit that's one of the reasons
why we choose this particular problem
and then we compare the processing time
on the experimental quantum processor
which was sort of order of 200 seconds
to collect three million beta screens
for fairly large sample against the
classical processing time and a
supercomputer and once the classical
processing times becomes unfeasible at
least in practice so far then we decided
we have achieved wanted supremacy so at
that point is what we Pamela is the
paper so I will start first by talking a
little bit about the complexity theory
underpinnings of this experiment as well
said this was nice
of experiment so to sample random
quantity records we only know how to do
that with classical computers we
actually estimate the probabilities we
don't know any other ways to simulate
the sampling but to actually simulate
this critical
honesty's and the computational cost at
least for 2d circuits
I've talked a bit about this because
this has changed a bit lately with some
new papers but onto these circuits the
computational cost is proportional to
the fidelity and it turns out that if
you have a polynomial classical sampling
algorithm then this implies that you can
estimate their probabilities using an
empirical so if you say well I see you
might have some other simulation method
that doesn't actually calculate
probabilities if this is a classical
algorithm it will have random bits and
if you have random bits and you can use
an empirical to sort of count how many
assignments of the random bits give you
a protocol that will imply that with an
empirical you can estimate probabilities
in contrast well just litter that this
also holds for globally unbiased noise
if you think that the noise in your
algorithm or your processor is probably
a bias even if you have a lot of noise
you can still estimate this
probabilities with an empirical
polynomial time in contrast if you're
actually sampling with a condiment
either there are no random bits anywhere
is just intrinsically quantum randomness
so even with an empirical
you cannot estimate probabilities if you
can sample so this difference between
let's say classical random bits on a
classical
polynomial algorithm and intrinsic
randomness in quantum sampling without
any classical random bits or any random
bits of research allows you to try to do
a separation in terms of complexity
theory and this is related to this
famous collapse of the polynomial
hierarchy so that's sort of the
underlying difference between
second quantum sampling for this problem
so what do we know about the complexity
theoretical complexity of sampling
random circles well we know that
estimating one probability is
sarpy hard in the worst case something
that we cannot do
even with an empirical is worst-case
sarpy hard now calculating probabilities
exactly is also sarpy in the average
case and i think bill will talk about
this later what we don't know is if the
average case estimation of probabilities
is also hard and if that was hard that
will imply that random circle sampling
is theoretically hard so that's the
result that were missing we know exact
average fairness and we know worst case
approximate hardness but we don't know
average case approximate harness
nevertheless we conjecture that this is
still hard so that's a good motivation
to use this particular computational
task to prove quantum supremacy and I
will nevertheless mention that without
error correction the fidelity decays in
an experiment exponentially in the
number of gates not just the number of
qubits and therefore asymptotically
we're not going to be able to sample our
asymptotically put in another way
synthetically classical algorithms in
terms of complexity will win because
classical algorithms scale exponentially
in the number of qubits and with other
correction quantum sampling the cases
potentially in the number of gates which
is a B respondent at the number of
qubits so once we set ourselves to work
on these computational tiles we need to
choose a figure of Merit and what we
develop is what we call presenter
prevents marking which is really an
estimate of the
so we're going to be running random
circles we want to estimate the fidelity
this works well in previous proposals
like randomized benchmarking it's also
related to quantum chaos in the sense
that if you have any discrete error you
will expect the trajectories without
errors and with errors deserted diverge
Maxima in some sense so this will allow
us to detect the fidelity because we're
sensitive to basically other errors
we're going to calculate the fidelity
for a full circle with up to 53 qubits
so it's this is system fidelity not just
the fidelity of the qubit gates and it's
a good measure to see if everything is
working so this is one of the reasons
when we choose this experiment that we
focus on this experiment for quite some
time especially in the experimental side
is that it allows us or it forces us to
make sure that the whole system is
working not just isolated to communicate
but Merriman simultaneously mitigates it
has to be fast this cetera so it's a
good benchmark moving towards fault
tolerance for an invitation the downside
is that this particular estimator of
fidelity requires to actually calculate
the ideal probabilities that you will
expect for a given random circuit and
that requires simulating this random
circuit which is potentially hard in the
number of qubits and in practice it just
becomes very expensive so once we get to
the point where we can not calculate
these probabilities anymore but we can
still sample with a quantum computer and
we circulate and we see that the
fidelity is good nevertheless we do more
things that extrapolation
then we that's what we decided well this
is what we meant by under supremacy
nevertheless there are other things you
can do that allow us to calculate the
fidelity of the whole system sort of
such as patch XV which I won't mention
later but it's basically you got the
circuit in half and we see
experimentally that if you remove all
the gates connecting the two valves you
get a fidelity in our experiment which
is very close to the fidelity of the
original circuit so this is a much more
efficient
because now you have two disconnected
circuits and allows you to calculate the
fidelity of a fairly large systems so
let me explain a little bit what's the
theory or what are the assumptions
behind this estimator of fidelity which
we call cross entropy networking so um
the first thing that we can do is well
we write the output density matrix as a
mixture of the ideal output with some
depolarization fidelity P and then some
noisy noise density matrix where we
simply correct the first of all there's
if you want to think in terms of quantum
trajectories you're gonna have discrete
errors if you sing a stochastic map it's
even simpler you're gonna have Polly
years basically so you can't have all
the three after it reserves in the
separator and we're going to define
observables that are going to depend on
the ideal probabilities this is the part
that is expensive because we need to run
this expensive classical simulations to
calculate these numbers so we calculate
or some output be the same q what is the
ideal probability to measure Q so our
observable is going to be some function
of these cell probabilities and then
what happens is that if we try to
estimate what world observer will be for
the noisy operator noisy density matrix
Chi the one where we keep accumulating
all the trajectories with errors then
well this is just dispersion that we get
we have these probabilities from the
noisy operator and these fancy oblivia
probabilities and now we're going to
make the assumption that because this is
a random shortcut the noisy
probabilities are going to be
uncorrelated with the ideal
probabilities and if they are and
they're going to average to one or two
to the N or whatever they were these the
dimension of the Hilbert space and if
these are something is correct then in
the sum here we can use the central
limit theorem because we're summing
some values with
sampling which is uncorrelated and what
we get is just they mean right with some
fruit to a seems that go like 1 over the
square root of the number of turns in a
similar summon in this particular
spreads in over all the different
probabilities some from the central
limit theorem everyone miss passed that
the value of the observable on the
operator is actually in statistically
independent on the details of the noise
so we know what the values of cylinder
is you pray trees and that boon allow us
to estimate the fidelity so I'm slightly
more formal and general way to say the
same thing is that we're going to assume
concentration of metric we're going to
assume that for our operator that we use
to estimate the fidelity if we estimate
the a simulator played another part
because this is a random circuit even
with this with noise but this is still
very random from concentration a master
would you expect these they are rates
over the hilbert space or generate the
spaces are very highly dimensional
sphere if you want plus food to Asians
that like 1 over the square root of the
dimensional vector space this is a
fairly generic result concentration of
measure in the case of the spheres for
lattice lemma has been used before
several words thin by chance for
instance is going to talk later in
quantum computing and it turns to this
kind of like a geometrical equivalent of
the central limit there so as long as
the concentration of measure works then
we don't really care about the details
of the noise we know what the probe will
give us when applied to the noise so
that's really all we need either this
concentration of measure in the
geometrical sense or here's the central
limit theorem if the probabilities from
the lowest rank related and once you
have that this force again our
observable which is just a fossil of the
via probabilities we know that dr.
applied to the noise is
independent of the specifics of the
noise so we know what the value is
without knowing too much about the noise
and then the tricky part is to design an
observable which actually gives you a
different signal for the ideal output so
you know concentration of matter is very
powerful if we don't design our
observable carefully the observer will
also concentrate for the ideal outputs
it will give the same value for the do
not put as for the noisy part and that's
why we need to calculate the ideal
probabilities when we define an
observable which is a function of the
deal probabilities is if you want an
observable or or you know function of
the ideal probability this is very
specific to the to the output state that
we expect in the ideal case so that's
why we worried concentration of measure
in the ideal case so then we're gonna
have some value here that we come to
because we choose observable for this
very specific state some value here
which is generic and that allows us to
solve for the depolarization fidelity or
which is uniform and of high enough
dimension is just the reality and that's
what we do thank you sir
yes please can you go back one slide so
how do you verify this concentration
measure there is part of the experiment
if you verify this right we've yeah
that's first life in the road we verify
this numerically so what we do basically
we look at assumed you have fun a
stochastic map which is the simplest
case and it's quite reasonable if you
have random circuits then what we do is
we calculate the observable for a
circuit with just one poly error and
then we compare with what we spent from
concentration of measure which is just
the average which totally makes the
state or the average value of the space
and then we see that in this the
difference between what we obtained or
our fidelity estimator let's say in this
case it was no rhythmic cross entropy
and the average value
is exponentially small so indeed it goes
like one over the square root of the
dimension for every poll year so in this
particular plot their success is the
depth of the circuit so you expect
concentration to word once you
randomized enough was the death of the
secret is large enough and the y-axis is
basically the difference between these
two values as measured by Carson's
ravine the dashed lines here is one over
the square root of the dimensions for a
different circuit size and we're
plotting here the median because there
are outliers for instance if there is a
seer just before the measurement and you
measure on DC basis that Ciera doesn't
do anything so taking the average
because you're tracking trying to look
at the displacement quantity there are
tires change the average too much but if
you look at quantiles
you see that the median indeed converges
to whatever sort of D and the error bars
here are quartiles and you see that you
know most of their typical errors do
give you concentration of measure and we
yeah and we look at these numerical
maybe says somebody who's raised a
question raised their hands and I'm just
looking at oh yeah
Benjamin Oh Burt does he want to ask a
question okay yeah what we
experimentally is we check for two
qubits for instance that where we can do
randomized switch working that indeed
what we get out of Crescent through P or
these estimators is the same as what you
get with randomize which party that was
experimental
I think Julia will talk later this week
over that and also we look at
measurement errors for instance you know
what happens if you only have if Miss
Manners dominate yes we get the correct
measurement errors and that houseworks
is pre-eminently thanks yeah thank you
that's a very good question
because he did this is an important
lesson for us so we check it numerically
an experimentally with two qubits where
we can compare with randomized switch
market so these are the specific obscure
rolls that we choose we started working
with
this cross-entropy estimator let me
course entropy because that's the more
standard form of entropy and it was
inspired by machine learning if you want
so then this is value will get the
experimental fidelity P D here is the
dimension of generator space which we
know of course because we know the
number of qubits
ungawa is just the Euler constant so
it's just a number and the average here
is our it's over the beta 3 instant to
sample so you sample in our case up to 3
millimeter strings you have to calculate
this ideal probabilities you take the
lower is big value of the ideal
probabilities and you just average
operate the probabilities that you
sample and allows you to get P the bar
the notes you are so can average over
circuit so we did in the largest
experiment in circles with three million
beta strings each and we averaged all of
them and that's the best estimator we
have of the actual experiment of reality
there is also actually an experiment we
do use this other form the linear
christian survey which we call a still
percent repeat because it's related this
general idea using concentration of
measure for an observable that depends
on idea functions and it's also called
linear force entropy in some other
branches of machine learning but what
did release is just a Marx likelihood
estimator of the depolarization Theory
TP if you assume a total daily price in
channel and this version the linear is
going to be is related to the
probability of heavy output that is got
introduced introduced which is using
quantum volume which is another measure
of how well you're doing with large
circuits in experiments so what we are
studied in this parents is we try both
of them and actually even a caveat good
probability and we check that all of
them give you again the same fidelity
because basically there's some same
concentration a measure applies in all
three cases you can define different of
struggles the reason why we end up
preferring linear constant
because it has a smaller variance okay
so we check the concentration of s or
numerically we just went through these
and this is how the algorithm looks like
for these quantum supremist experiment
so we're star by 2 since from random
circuit we sample around a million times
in this frame and it was more like 3
million for tenth circuit's so we sample
from the from actual experimental
processor we calculate the ideal
probabilities for the circuit so this is
the expensive simulation part and for
instance once you have the VL
probabilities you can calculate the
cross entropy or the linear percent
repiy and that's our estimator of
fidelity and the goal is to be able to
do these with circles that are large
enough so you cannot calculate the
probabilities anymore or not the
probabilities in the sample that again
is what we call supremacy so this was
the chip that was used in the spring
meniscal Sycamore it has 54 qubits
53 of them were used in the experiment
basically because one cable wasn't
working when they called it the cheap
and then the team was work so well and
they didn't want to warm it up anymore
until we finish this pyramid but he has
54 qubits and it also has 196 control
knobs and one important feature of this
chip is that the couplers so here in
this picture the gray crosses decide the
qubits which are superconducting qubits
flavor of transplants the blue boxes
does our couplers and the couplers are
controllable in this chip there are just
little couplers they have an independent
control knob and so we found out we have
to use this chip we started with a
different chip that didn't have
controller couplers because that allow
us to tune the couplers the coupling
between qubits very close to zero and
that's the way we could address
crosstalk with her previous chip we
select one that had more qubits less
controls with Mercury bits it was very
hard
to get rid of sufism crossed off for
this payment to work so as I said one
reason what we focus on diseases Freeman
is that it gives us a measure of system
finality it was again a very good system
engineering goal and that's one of the
results of of trying to do this we move
to an adjustable coupler design which we
think it's actually probably needed for
fault tolerance as well because you also
want to remove crossed I'll keep you
Sergei oh yes there's there's a question
from the from the audience are there
this questioner you know selsun asks I
was wondering how sensitively the value
of xB B depends on the details of the
random sampling of the circuits ie do
they need to be perfectly hard random
yeah that's a good question they are not
perfectly high random because to you
know for two qubits you can do perfectly
high randoms records but not for 53
cubits the depth to be perfectly high
random will be exponential in the number
of qubits so I guess in principle you
just need to be a to design and there
has been indeed a lot of interesting
work on trying to see what death do you
need for for to design even
theoretically maybe Jen's we'll talk
about it later
in practice we checked numerically you
know so up to even up to 53 qubits we
could do numerix for circuits that are
not the hardest circuits and we
basically check that the distribution
the the output probabilities look random
enough the simplest check that we do is
if you have a hard random circuit and
you look at the distribution of the
ideal probabilities the distribution of
the deal clarity's itself sees as
potential which is calling this context
of Porter Thomas distribution because
it's related to quantum care so we check
that we have enough depth to get a
porter thomas distribution and we also
check other statistical properties of
the distribution of ideal probabilities
like the inverse participation ratios
and so it will be great you
could prove that we have to design which
is probably good enough but in practice
we just do it numerically NP we're
confident that we have enough depth but
they are not perfectly high random you
just needed to be random enough for
concentration of Messer to work and I
think cousin Tracy no-mess returns to
work very well you know what I think to
design is good enough mr. Perrotti thank
you um hi I said yeah I wonder if I can
ask you very quickly um sorry so can you
is there is there something more you can
say that would be understandable to a
theoretician about how these
controllable couplers help you help you
deal with crosstalk right it's basically
yes so the difference is in standard
super I mean you need to control qubits
obviously right so in most super
computing qubits platforms the qubits
are always couple there is always some
capacitance or inductance between
between the qubits the qubits are in
circles there is always something that
turns for instance so that means there
is always a coupling between them always
so what you do if you don't want to have
the coupling is you basically turn the
qubits of resonance you you know the
coupling can be like 20 megahertz you
set them if you can like gigahertz apart
so their array of resonance and in the
rotating wave for instance you know like
the couple is pretty readily small and
you sort of ignore it but it's always
there now the problem is when you want
to do gate then you start you have to
move the couple the qubits close to each
other then when you move two qubits
close to each other so you know they are
not of residence anymore and this
coupling that is always there becomes
effective then they tend to get also
close to other qubits in the
neighborhood because you know they start
colliding in frequencies so you get more
crust on the difference with these
adjustable coupler series the cut the
qubits are now always close in frequency
and there is no
you know the inductance that you have in
the middle is sort of an adjustable
inductance so you can actually turn the
Dutton's off and that's complicated to
do they are actually the couplers
themselves are sort of qubits also
they're sort of trust bones they're just
working on a different regime and then
what you do is you just kind of tune the
transmen in the middle of resonance
without actually having to move the
qubits around and that gives you you
know more Liberty to make sure that you
don't introduce you know unwanted
coupler with other neighboring qubits so
it's kind of an adjustable inductance
basically do you build a circuit which
is an inductance that you can adjust and
you turn it to zero okay I think I'm
ready questions so let's see right so
these are sort of experimental results
at the level of two qubit gates so the
black line here is single qubit error
rates and delicious interrelated
histograms you can see there are rights
of all the qubits in this particular
chip of the 53 qubits and you see
they're around point 15 poly error rate
we think is better to quote poly rate
which is a bit higher than one minus
average theory which is the standard
number that is cool but the poly right
is what that's to plug your circuits you
can apply a player right to any it's
arbitrary of the dimension of the system
in which you measure it so it's pretty
good fidelity and simultaneous this is
very important is when we do still given
gates in all the qubits at the same time
so you see that the single thing right
is very close to the isolated rate so
even if you are doing single qubit gates
you know the qubits at the same time you
are not introducing more errors because
of crosstalk now with two qubit gates is
a bit different the isolated polarities
36 which is also pretty good and this is
for particular guy which we call
Sycamore which is close to a nice swap
these they took it with gate when you
measure it simultaneously so that means
you are doing as many to give it gas as
you can across the chip so every cubed
participates in a ticket gate the error
rate doubles so yeah we have this
adjustable couplers that removes a lot
of crosstalk right not enough because if
it was exactly you know if all the
crosstalk was to completely enough then
simultaneous and insulated will be the
same memory so it's double but is not
too bad it is still good enough to
render larger circuits and then they
read that error in this particular chip
has a very good because of some design
problem discuss sensitive proof and it
was around 3.8 percent without error
when measuring all the cubes of the same
time which was fairly high so this is
how we run random circuits we basically
do simultaneous gates or not qubits it's
kind of a general-purpose algorithm I'll
talk about this more at then and we just
run sequences of single qubit gates and
to commit gates for some number of
cycles and we recycle is mitigates in
other qubits and singing educates you
know the qubits so the single qubit
gates take around 25 microseconds their
microwave gates and they ticket gates
they are very fast that's another
advantage of using these adjustable
couplers when you can turn it on you can
actually turn on a fairly large amount
of coupling so the two quid gates take
only 12 milliseconds so this is the
experimental results for some circuits
that we call verifiable circuits so the
x-axis is the number of qubits the
number of cycles for service for
yes sir 28 cycles you can single entity
with gates and the first interesting
thing to note is that we measure the
poly error rates in simultaneous node
that was a couple of slides ago and if
you just multiply the probability of not
having an error where you get the poly
error rates from these simultaneous rate
measurements then you get this line the
black line and that tends to align
really well with the fidelity that we
measure with person to be benchmarking
for the full circuit so this particular
circuits turns out to have some hidden
symmetry that's what we call them where
if I was very good so we were able to
actually perform curse and agreements
marking for the full circuit got 53
qubits that 40 that was around five
hours with one medium course so it's
five hours but you know a lot of CPI
hours five million CPI hours per circuit
and we did ten of them so this was more
than 50 million corridors to get the red
circle there here some of these circuits
with 42 and 53 qubits they were done in
the julik supercomputing center and
these are figures of 238 qubit you can
do it in a worker station if you have up
to four types of RAM that allows you to
238 qubits so those are the red circles
just occur Center which marking of the
full circuit now if you cut this
occurred in half as I mentioned at the
beginning then the cross-entropy is easy
to do because you only need to calculate
the probabilities some half as many
qubits
so how 54 is still 27 does a circuit
which is easy to simulate and what is
interesting is that even though now the
circuit is cut in half so you don't have
integrity there is a lot less and back
city if you want this is ready to seem
like when we presented before this
and they should cut on the right and
then we just multiply that it is we get
these blue crosses which align again
with the red circles with the estimate
from the discrete Ramallah so what this
tells us is that basically the ability
that we're getting is sort of
independent of the amount of
entanglement and the complexity if you
want of the particular circuit that
we're running so that's kind of the
best-case scenario you know aligned with
check about the discrete error model is
working when you measure the errors in
the simultaneous cross entropy so this
is good sign for you know future fault
our road map at least to the level of
sensitivity of these experiments of
course you know you need to do
experiments with more sensitivity to
measure you know crossed a lot smaller
levels but to the level of sensitivity
this is prime and this is promising and
then we do something similar with the
lighted circuits which is something in
between really remove some of the gates
across the cut and it turns out that
with this algorithm that was planar met
these two makes this simulates the
simulation a lot easier and again
everything aligns so these were the
circuits that we could verify because
they have this hidden symmetry actually
what happened is we thought initially
these were like our supremacist records
but then in the process of checking that
they need couldn't could not be
simulated
we found this symmetry by looking sort
of as mid decompositions of okay it's
close to the cut and things like that
and it turned out that we could simulate
them so one nice consequence of that is
that when we could do this full circuit
and the downside is that for a while we
thought we were not gonna get supremacy
because we could simulate these records
but then we found out how to remove this
symmetry by sort of changing how we do
two qubit gates across the cut and
that's what we call now the supremacy
circuits and what we did at that point
is we were now interested in the
supremacy because we had this data
across entropy
seemed to work well the bees that are
Mollison to well so we just took
sir cut at fifty three cubits at
different depths all the way from 12 to
20 the black line again is the discrete
error model and we will do a lie that
Patrick series part 6 vegan is you just
cut the circuits in two halves it aligns
well with what they discrete error model
predict but we couldn't check the food
Mars and coolness of the data if you go
look for a paper in nature and look or
the link to the data you can download
that be it rings for all the circuits on
all the full circuits that we have not
verify so this is you know sort of a
nice check for the future whenever
algorithms or hardware improves enough
so you can actually do this full percent
appeal and you can check if it aligns
with the rest of the straight cuts for
now okay so let me tell you a little bit
more about the algorithm that we use in
the simulations beyond 38 qubits
including these 50 million cores for
these circuits with 53 qubits and 14
cross entropy cycles so it's what we
call a stirring and fireman hybrid
simulation and basically what you do is
you have these two qubit gates in the
cut remember in Patrick TV we just
remove all the gates in the cut now we
want to simulate this circuit with two
qubit gates across the same cut so to
sort of separate them for the simulation
we just do a Smitty composition of the
two qubit gates across the card which
will look like this and it will be a sum
of gates that go on the left and on the
right and the sum is weighted by this
mid coefficients now this will be you
know for one to commit gauge you have
four Smith coefficients for this
particular to communicates that we use
which are related to I sockets if you
have many two qubit gates in the cut
then you basically has to have to sum
the products of all the possible its
mean decompositions of the gates across
the car
so you need to perform this um and the
number of terms in the sound goes goes
like well this is potentially in the
combination well it is the number of
hrus mid coefficients that you can
choose you know possible combinations so
it's exponential in the number of two
cubed kids across the cut so you have to
do a lot of simulations but every one of
them is now easy to do because for every
one of these choices of asthma
decomposition for the to compete against
of course I God you just have circles
with 27 qubits but you can do it
physically so you're not doing millions
of simulations but every one of them is
kind of easier and that's why we did
these 53 cubed simulations with that 14
it turns out that if you don't need if
you are not trying to do Christian
turkey but just sort of simulating
sampling then you only need to sum a
number of terms in this sum proportional
to the fidelity that you want reached us
in this frame and it was around 0.2
percent fidelity so if you early some
point two percent of the of the path in
the Sun then that will be equivalent
computationally to what the quantum
computer itself is to it
now for one distr cut this is 44 when
these figures are actually efficient
with the simulations these are some new
results which you can do with magics
promoted States or but for 2d at least
synthetically cannot do these so in any
case this is the technique that we use
to calculate Decker or Center P 453
qubits that 14 so this is the data
supplement of our paper where we
basically compare the best algorithms we
can run with the with the cost of
sampling in the quantum computer so one
thing that you can do is if you can
start it from wavefunction well then
that tends to be
the officiant but at least using ramen
to summon supercomputer you can only get
around 48 gibbets or something like that
we were using 53 qubits now there is
some proposal to use the disk so that
will be interesting to see if it
actually works and I guess our
philosophy here will come and later on
is we wanted to compare an experiment on
a processor which actual computational
experiments so we didn't consider these
because nobody has run simulations of
the sizing disk ever say will be
interesting to see if you can actually
do it and then we used after you know we
ran out of these which are the
simulations that people actually do in
practice then we do this running an
algorithm which has smaller memory
requirements but the accommodation cost
is nice potential I'm the number of
gates across the car so what happened is
that for the circuits that we can
actually run if we just extrapolate from
simulations that we perform so we don't
do them for simulation we don't do all
the parts but we do a subset of the pads
and the cost is linear in the number of
parts because there is no communication
between different parts then we
extrapolate like 600 years for death 16
and all the way to 10,000 years for
there 20 years in this algorithm so of
course algorithms will improve and
that's kind of what we spent improving
for the last years but we think is
important to actually perform the
experiments computational experiments as
well you know because it's hard to
really find out what's the actual
runtime on an algorithm when you run it
in practice and for instance is not
clear if you can run using the fault
disk of a supercomputer because it's
never been done before and then in the
meantime you know we keep increasing the
number of qubits so we hope to be we
hope that you know we have cross
supremacy eventually algorithms will
catch up probably but we will have it
processor and we think that is sort of a
transition once we cross supremacy the
experiment will improve faster than
classical evidence at classical hardware
now in the turn set in terms of
classical algorithms there are there has
been some other new advances which I
want to touch upon so another method
that we didn't use for most of our
computations in this particular paper is
this what we call feminine rhythms or
transfer network instructions so we work
on these but it just didn't work for
these very large circuits in our
implementation so what you do is
basically you have a quantum circuit
this is a standard representation of a
quantum circuits where the plot the
boxes are single qubit gates of ticket
gates and you can think of one of these
quantum gates as a tensor so you map the
circle to start of tensor representation
or graphical model and then you
basically want to contrast all these
tensor operations now typically we know
that the cost of the tensor contraction
is going to be exponentially near the
minimum to the circuit so in the minimum
of either the depth and the dimension
which is number of qubits or if you have
enough depth then you just contrast sort
of as you go through the reach one
simulation so it's just expensive number
of qubits good last couple recently is a
journey gray has been improving
algorithms to find out what is the
optimal contraction ordering so the
tricky part about these performing these
payment simulations to transfer Network
simulations is that you have to contrast
all these indexes and the cost of the
simulation itself is very dependent on
how smart you are about what indexes you
contract first so this is a difficult
problem Johnny gray has improved
significantly what are the URIs things
for this problem so these are plots from
his paper when in particular for
sycamore 53 supported circuits in an
experiment
our best contractions were basically the
ones which used our this yellow squares
q-flex which is a very efficient
algorithm in terms of computational
efficiency it's very efficient as using
a juice you know the competition of
cycles properly so we run this algorithm
in Summit and we achieve a 92% peak
efficiency so 92% of the theoretical
maximum efficiency in Summit and the
average efficiency was bigger than 50%
so it's a really efficient algorithm it
was designed to be efficient but it's
not very flexible in terms of
contraction or drains and this is what
you're having fun with some heuristic
which is based on community detection
everyone get into the details but you
can read the paper he found contraction
are things that are in terms of with
sort of twenty times sorry then we do
increases by 20 so that means the
exponent B creases by 20 and if you
translate the width into computational
cost so the number of operations that
use pad to to find out well it has you
know decreases significantly from ten to
the twenty seven for two flags and s22
10 to the 18 sort of flop operations so
Johnny gray actually run this algorithm
on one single NVIDIA GPU and it
calculates that for there's 20 which are
supremacist circuits if you want to stay
just one amplitude at 25% fidelity that
will be around seven million seconds
those are these numbers now some it has
30,000
CPUs sorry GPUs so that would be three
days but the GPUs in Summit are more
efficient than the GPUs that you need
use so that will be at most four hours
so using this new algorithm or these new
contractionary you can actually
calculate at least one amplitude with 5%
fidelity in seven so I think that's very
interest you know if you want to
calculate 3,000,000 amplitudes as we did
in this pyramid that will still be three
years so I
this is doable but is certainly better
than the 10,000 years of the high
retirement so I think this is a
significant improvement I mean you want
to do a course entropy which of course
is what we need to defer the spray mm
well that's still three million years
for the larger circuits unfortunately we
cannot do cross entropy and check the
data for the largest supremacist
vehicles yet okay so what did we learn
from this experiment well we learned
that the fidelity that we get with
christen to be women's working was the
same for the full circuits the bad
circuits would you cut in half and you
have you know significantly less
entanglement or complexity and it was
actually the same that you get from the
predicted error model so the errors if
you measure errors lives in simultaneous
mode where you're already taking into
account the crystal with your nearest
neighbors doesn't seem to depend on them
time I made a computational complexity
as you would expect from quantum
mechanics but you know this this is
something that you have to check as your
increase in the amount of complexity in
the system so we check that the the
discrete error model works and this
underlines fault tolerance or quantum
error correction so that's good news at
least level of sensitivity experiment we
increase complexity
threat of by more than 10 sir there's so
many to tie thing over previous
experiments in essence that we properly
be of these quasi random estate in a
very large scale with the space with
dimension 10 to the 16 and quantum
mechanics is to work within this is
interesting actually were in the paper
with the impress scale introduces the
the name when the supremacy was actually
talking about this highly complex will
tear us you know one frontier in science
that you want to explore experimental is
I think that's what we do in this paper
and finally we kind of challenged
extended Church three thesis in this
sense that we have this experimental
process
sir which is sort of one centimeter
square you know it means this larger
dilution refrigerator but the tip itself
is pretty small we're kind of competing
you know with the largest supercomputers
summit which is sort of two foot fields
or basketball fields worth of you know
transistors and you know so far we're
performing a gravitational task which is
unifying two computers but they still a
well-defined temptation on tasks where
it's weakened with this centimeter chip
but you cannot do with a supercomputer
so we think this is a challenge to the
standard church-turing thesis that says
that organizational models are
equivalent in terms of efficiency and it
seems to be true sir this is to be false
according to ponder me there and it
seems to be false experimentally as well
so in the last four minutes I will just
mention an experiment that we have done
recently which is just to mention if
here basically to make the point that
this is indeed a general on the
processor so we calculate the ground
state energy for hydrogen chain above 12
hydrogen's we use her typical States
this experiment is simple to simulate
because her to focus midfield you can
simulate is classically nicely but it's
a good man's work to see how the quantum
processor is working so this is sort of
the circuit that we use to prepare the
Granite State
well the Hardy for current state and
then relationally and then master
[Music]
sort of the terms that you need to
measure the energy variation which turns
out to be just the one side to induce
density matrix as potassium valleys on
the way to 12 qubits
we compile these two predicates which
are given through tensions in a romantic
language with the scraps which out of
the square root of the Sigma gates that
we use women we get all the way to 72
square root of 5 swabs and 108 to
communicate sorry and 108 single qubit
rotations and one thing that was
interesting and performing this
experiment is that even though
well first of all you can do a selection
because this is a real estate hurdle for
k-state these given rotations conserve
the number of fermions or basically
conserve the number of once in your beta
screens so by throwing away B this means
that they'll have half occupancy then
you post a lot you reduce measurement
errors for instance and sort of t1
errors even with post-election you get
fidelity a semester by fidelity witness
approach for these four million Carson
estates which is under there of only 10%
this is Error but then you can do
purifications because this is a hard to
focus state you have the one at the ends
and using represent ability properties
of these muller states you can sort of
project to the closest peter state and
that increases the fidelity
significantly or produces the errors to
sort of around 90 there's two run like
two percent or something like that and
then if you do we create so you tuned
your parameters to sort of minimize then
in irradiation of their square give it
lower so I think the interesting part of
this experiment is sort of improving
this or medication techniques which are
indeed going to be necessarily we want
to really perform con discrimination in
nicely near-term experimental processors
so with that I would like to conclude
thank you very much okay great thanks so
let's see should we ask should we see if
there's any questions from the audience
maybe I can ask you a question most
people are still thinking about other
questions of course there are under
eighty seven people recall and maybe
take the time to ask a question so one
question about that so you were
experiments on the Bristlecone chip that
you did before right so you could that
that didn't have tunable couplers I
think so no you know like what
experiments failed right in the end this
worked but the the Bristlecone ship who
wasn't good enough and how did you see
that and drive I guess yeah what happen
is the bridge work on cheap you know not
so yeah you could perform two qubit
gates right the two gates were really
different because of the particular
details of how you implement equivocates
when you have qubits of resonance
because the coupler is how we solve so
they were constituency or control not to
to communicate and you could just choose
two qubits and calibrate them and do it
to communicate with those to give it
fine
I know you know the qubits around you
were sort of from the ground state you
like they don't exist
very negative state and you can do these
two key with gates perfectly well you
could get good realities now the problem
is for these random circuits you need to
have two qubit gates basically in all
qubits at the same time right otherwise
you know it would be just too much depth
and you are gonna be killed by team one
just the coherence and the problem is if
you try to do two qubit gates in many
qubits at the same time neighboring here
it's at the same time then it was just
too hard to calibrate those q it's
roughly to remove crosstalk so once in
basically got too much crosstalk
basically you get too much crosstalk you
could probably remove a lot of crosstalk
by calibrating better because you know
if your movie
you're never in Cuba to some other place
in frequency it starts affecting this
one Cuba but you can in principle you
know sort of a coherent coupling so you
can in principle try to calibrate it
away if you are smart enough with a
smarter control to sort of remove the
coupling with control because he's
coherent it's not just the coherence but
this the problem is just too hard it was
too hard to try to engineer the controls
for all the qubit simultaneously to
remove this coherent coupling so yeah in
in essence we we just couldn't get away
from crosstalk if you keep working on
that maybe you know you're you're smart
enough fundamentally you can improve you
your control because he's coherent but
it was just too hard so you know at the
same time what people were working
actually on this chip with with thermal
covers for quite some time people like
Charles Neil and Pedram and others and
it just turned out to work really well
and as people were struggling really
hard you know to remove the cross loss
of control that's a pretty people said
well this is just harder to do this chip
is working really well and everybody
kind of moved to to the copper sycamore
chip
Sergio there's a question from the chat
but maybe it's a question for part two
of this talk during experimental Tuesday
but the question is how come the single
qubit gates are slower than the then two
qubit gates right that's an interesting
question and indeed Julian but the basic
thing is that with this tune about
couplers you can turn it off but you can
actually turn them off you know to some
fairly large value of coupling and your
other qubits
are sort of quiet and you know so you
turn up a fairly strong coupling between
two neighboring qubits without turning
on the other couplers it's just that the
body of copper that you get so I guess
I'm an interesting question is why you
don't do single qubit single qubit gates
faster which are microf gates
so you could increase the amplitude and
then you know you could do them faster
and I guess the main reason is that
these superconducting qubits they have
not just surround one they also have the
second energy level 1380 level and if
you try to do single - it gets very fast
you're trying to drive vegetations
between the ground state in the first
estate but you start leaking into the
second excited state and some more
because you're you know it's harder to
decouple from higher energy levels so do
you start getting leakage so the basic
answer is you're limited to twenty five
minutes seconds at least corny because
you want away tickets to higher I have a
quick question here so in terms of area
models you said your results are
consistent with having local you know
maybe single qubit errors or possibly
two qubit so would you have been able to
tell the difference if let's say that
you had you had error spread out locally
over over ten cubits you know you had
these patches of errors would you have
been able to tell that that was not the
case well it depends on the probability
I guess I mean this experiment you know
has I guess a limited sensitivity right
because we're talking about you know
there are probabilities for their 0.3%
are you know particular idiots so I
think if you have spread errors which
are ten times smaller and they are
really spread between many qubits then
you will not be able to detect them with
this particular experiment right because
you know they will be masked by the
higher errors that that we're getting so
you know it's quite possible that there
are still significant correlated errors
but you know yes the lower probability
than this is new for this experiment so
it's very important to do more tailor
experiments to look at that particular
question
thanks I think I'd like to step in as
the conference organizer and say we
would like us to keep fairly close to
the schedule there is in fact quite a
lot of further discussion come showing
up in both in the Q&A and the chat but
my reading of is most of it also address
can be addressed by Julie and Kelly
tomorrow so I would suggest we adjourn
and thank Sergio for this talk and we
will have the promised well not ten
minute break but four minute break
anyway until again sighs art is ready to
go okay great thanks Sergio thank you